my name is Nicole Hannah Jones and I'm a
staff writer at the New York Times
Magazine
I think investigative reporting is the
most critical of all reporting because
that's the reporting that holds power
accountable and we need to be the ones
who are holding those who marginalize
our communities who exploit our
communities accountable the person whom
I consider a trailblazer is Ida B wells
she was a black woman born into slavery
in 1862 who went on to innovate
investigative reporting techniques and
really is the reason that we began to
pay attention in this country to the
scourge of lynchings so when I was a kid
during Black History Month there'd
always be about five black people that
you always learned about and I to be
wells was one of them and so one day I
decided to read her autobiography and I
was just completely struck by how a
woman who had been born into slavery
could be so audacious could be so
courageous she was a woman who fought
for all women to be treated as equals
she was a woman who hyphenated her name
when she got married before American
women did that she was one of the first
people to challenge racial segregation
when she sued the railroad for trying to
force her to sit in the colored section
of the car she was just someone unlike
anyone I had read about in history I
went on to co-found an investigative
reporting organization is called the IDB
wealth Society and we tried to train and
mentor other journalists of color to do
investigative reporting we named it
after her to show that there's a long
legacy and tradition of black
investigative reporting and of course my
twitter handle is ida bay wells which is
in honor of who i consider to be the
baddest journalist that this country has
ever created i just tried to be a
straight shooter like she was she was a
woman who did not know her place who
refused to conform to what society says
she should do and she was a race woman
she only wanted to do reporting that was
going to expose racial inequality and
that's been really the driving passion
of my own reporting
America was not yet America but this was
the moment it became 1619 project was a
project by the New York time to
commemorate the 400th anniversary of
slavery on what would become the United
States of America
and the project argues that nothing
about modern American life has been
untouched by that decision and through a
series of essays poems original short
stories we try to play slavery at the
very center of the American story and so
in many ways to me the 16:19 project is
trying to force a reckoning with a
country that was founded both on the
ideas of freedom and the enslavement a
fully one-fifth of the population and we
will never be able to get past that
original sin if we don't acknowledge
that the sin was committed